[Music]
foreign
David was just mentioning it President
Biden will be in the Valley tomorrow
which will create some traffic issues no
doubt the airport connector along with
Maryland Parkway from Tropicana to
Russell will be closed from 12 15 to 12
45 in the afternoon then tomorrow
evening between 5 30 and 6 30 several
closures as the president moves around
the valley including the airport
connector as you take a look at the map
here the 15 North between the 215 and
the 95 and then the 95 from the
spaghetti Bowl to Summerlin Parkway
virtually right in the middle of rush
hour tomorrow most of our major arteries
could be affected Summerland Parkway
will be closed in both directions from 7
30 until 8 o'clock and of course we'll
bring you some of the highlights of the
president's visit tomorrow